- [Kelly] How are the
comedy shows going though?
- Pretty good.
- Yeah?
- I mean, the crowds are back. It's nice.
- It's fun. The energy.
- Ya know. Yeah.
I've been doing a lot of improv
and that's the nicest because
you don't have to prepare anything.
- I love improv. I love watching it.
- Would you ever do it?
- I don't know, but I
think I would do that
before anything else.
- [Nicole] Do you want to?
Because I can get, I could hook you up.
- [Kelly] I would, I would maybe try it.
(audience applauds)
I think it would be fun.
- Would you?
- I think it would be fun.
I like acting on stage.
Like I grew up in musical
theater- like theater,
- [Nicole] Mm-hmm.
- and I like doing it the one time
and you're in the mode, like at that's
- This is one time
and you never do it again.
- [Kelly] I know. So it's fun that way
- [Nicole] There's someone
else on stage to be like,
Hey friend, let's do something else.
- [Kelly] But even if
it's bad, it's funny.
- I think so
- Yes.
- Okay. Kelly, I'm holding you to this.
You're willing to do
an improv show with me?
- [Kelly] I'm going to be
like nervous but I would do it
- [Nicole] Really?
- Just for fun. Just for
like, I've never done
- Well, I mean, you're
not doing it for money.
(laughing)
- [Kelly] No, no. I just, mean, no
- Nobody gets paid to do
improv. It's all imaginary.
(laughing)
- [Kelly] I didn't mean
- This is me paying you for improv.
- [Kelly] No, I meant,
I meant like I've never
done anything like that.
- This is exciting
- Other than like in in
high school doing stuff
- Yeah. I'm gonna hold you to this.
- [Kelly] So who do you do this?
Do you do this with friends?
- I do it with friends lately.
Seth Rogan has joined the show that I do.
Yeah there's,
- [Kelly] He was just on here.
I'll tell you what I did
not realize about him.
I knew he had a great laugh
but like it is the most infectious
and like you end up laughing
so much at his laugh.
You can't stop.
- Yeah. On stage.
Sometimes you'll like
get into a giggle fit
because you'll hear his
giggle and you're like,
oh I am being funny.
- [Kelly] Oh my God. And he and his laugh,
I've never heard anything like it.
- It's great.
- So you do it with
friends whenever you're,
you're up there. So that's
kind of, that's comfortable.
- [Nicole] Yeah. We do
kinda feed off each other.
It's called the Last Improv Show.
It's like twice a month.
Honestly. I'm gonna get you to do it.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I think you're gonna have fun.
- [Kelly] Okay. I say yes to things
now that I never, well like this show
(laughter)
and I never would've said yes to before.
- Yeah sure, I'll host a show
- Even if I fail,
it's when you get older, you don't care.
So you, I actually don't know
that I care in my twenties either.